so first I want to start by saying how
much I loved this movie man I have a lot
of things to talk to you guys about I
want to start with I think Watchmen is
the best thing on TV right now did you
know when you got involved it was going
to be this good I was like anyone with
half a brain able to put together the
fact that the best graphic novel ever
written was going to be paired with one
of the great innovators of storytelling
on television of our time the
generational talent of Damon Lindelof
you put those two together and then
Regina King as the lead which I was told
they were in negotiations when I was
offered my role and yeah I had a sense
that it was going to be something pretty
special did I know it was gonna be as
extraordinary as it is no because it
just didn't even beat my expectations I
agree with that and Regina's work on the
show is stunning so like I have time for
on that I want to jump into why I get to
talk to the two of you guys this movie's
incredible and what you guy what
everyone delivered in this film is is so
important and can you sort of talk about
the fact that films like this they're
really tough to get made it's not like a
speaking of superhero things but it's
not filled with explosions and
superheroes this is like about real
people and this is one of those films
that I'm just so happy God made yeah
that's a testament to Bryan Stevenson
first brightened a book just mercy
giving us that blueprint and then for
Warner Brothers having the hoot spot to
want to get behind Michael B Jordan and
his diversity initiative program that
he had attached to this movie and all
the things that came along with telling
this story and making it an actual movie
so hopefully what this movie can do is
encourage other studios or other writer
directors that take on this kind of
material that can potentially go out and
create some conversation to make our
society better moving forward so
hopefully this will start a trend I
think you've touched on something
because the mid-level mid budget level
drama finds less and less space in our
culture they're just not making them so
much anymore
and indeed Michael B Jordan and Dustin
Daniel [ __ ] and Bryan Stevenson Plus
Warner Brothers frankly putting putting
putting the cash on the Barrelhead to
make this movie hats off to all of them
because these movies just aren't made so
much anymore completely I think what
Brian Brian Brian story is unbelievable
and what I love about this movie besides
telling his story is hopefully it will
shine a light on his organization and
get more people the help they need for
getting off on these stupid petty crimes
that they're in car serated for life can
you sort of talk about how a film like
this can really shine a light and
hopefully raise awareness it's a in a
sense this is a gateway this movie
because it's telling one story the story
of Walter McMillian
and what Brian Stevenson did literally
to save this man's life and to take him
off death row where he was erroneously
placed and that allows you in to to ask
well who is Brian Stevenson and then you
understand that he's devoted decades to
this that he has saved countless people
from death row or life in prison that he
has a museum in Montgomery Alabama
associated with the equal
Justice Initiative that this is a true
American hero who has had an impact on
thousands of lives and hopefully this
movie just gives you a glimpse into that
and then you'll pursue the issues
further
I agree 1,000% I can't say it no better
and then Tim just said it I really mean
it congratulations on the movie I'm so
happy it was made both of you did such
great work thank you